alguna vez has jugado serpientes y
escaleras a veces los números de los
dados nos ayudan a sumar casillas y
avanzar pero otras veces caemos en una
serpiente y tenemos que regresar algunas
casillas te has fijado que esto es muy
parecido a sumar y restar practiquemos
nuestro cálculo mental en situaciones
donde tengamos que agregar o quitar
elementos para encontrar un resultado
ayer le regalaron 10 rosas a ana pero
amanecieron dos marchitas cuántas rosas
le quedan en este caso a 10 le tenemos
que quitar 2 y el resultado es 8 rosas
sigamos con nuestra práctica juan
preparó 8 bolsitas de dulces para
regalar a sus compañeros de clase pero
solo asistieron tres compañeros cuantas
bolsitas de dulces le quedaron aquí a
ocho le tenemos que quitar tres lo que
nos da cinco bolsitas de dulces y aunque
no lo creas también podemos usar las
matemáticas en la cocina
veamos rosita necesita seis huevos para
hacer su receta de pastel si en casa
solo tiene cuatro cuántos huevos tiene
que comprar pausa el vídeo e intenta
resolverlo cuando tengas la respuesta
continúa con el vídeo para saber si tu
resultado fue el correcto en el ejemplo
de las bolsitas de dulces quitamos
elementos pero hay otra forma en la que
podemos calcular el resultado tenemos
que contar cuánto nos falta para
completar los 6 huevos a partir de los 4
que ya tenemos tenemos 4 y entonces
decimos 5 y 6 entonces rossi está tiene
que comprar 2 huevos más
ya vimos situaciones en las que debemos
de quitar elementos a través de
operaciones de resta ahora veamos
situaciones donde hay que agregar
elementos para esto usaremos operaciones
de suma en el salón de carlos hay una
pecera con seis peces la maestra llevó
tres más cuantos peces hay en total la
operación sería la siguiente 6 más 3 es
igual a 9
alejandra recibió en su cumpleaños
cuatro cuentos un disco y tres muñecas
cuántos regalos recibió en total
realicemos la suma a cuatro le sumamos
uno y agregamos tres o sea cuatro más
uno más tres lo que nos da un total de
ocho regalos ahora ya sabes que cuando
agregas elementos estás realizando una
suma y cuando quitas elementos haces una
resta sigue practicando